did you know that the Republicans don't
like President Obama and that President
Obama doesn't really like the
Republicans yeah I guess you probably
knew that that's not news but the New
York Times had an interesting piece that
came out yesterday about how the
Democrats actually the congressional
Democrats especially are actually
frustrated with President Obama as well
the article was titled Obama is seen as
frustrating by his own party and we're
gonna get to a quote from it but a lot
of it had to do with the conversation
that Harry Reid who's a Democrat
obviously was having with Mitch
McConnell a Republican about Iraq and
Harry Reid went to the President and
sort of wanted help and basically Obama
just brushed him aside and said you deal
with it Harry and the article basically
goes to how Obama kinda seems distant
even with his own allies in his own
party so let's look at a quote from the
article in one sense mr. obama's
response was a reminder of what made him
such an appealing figure in the first
place his almost innate aversion to the
partisans wobbles that have left
Americans so jaded and disgruntled with
their political system but nearly six
years into his term with his popularity
at the lowest of his presidency mr.
Obama appears remarkably distant from
his own party on Capitol Hill with his
long neglect of would be allies catching
up to him and it goes on in interviews
nearly two dozen Democratic lawmakers
and senior congressional aides suggested
that mr. Obama's approach has left him
with few loyalists to effectively manage
the issues erupting abroad at at home
and could imperil his efforts to leave a
legacy in his final stretch in office so
I think there's a lot of interesting
stuff here you know he was getting a lot
of [ __ ] this week because he's been on
vacation all week while all this obvious
Isis stuff is happening and Ferguson he
did go back to DC to issue a statement
you know people are always attacking
presidents for taking vacations I mean
they got to be human too but this one
does seem particularly odd to me at
least so what should we make of the
Democrats cuz this just like lame duck
guy you're six years in six and a half
years in we know you're almost out and I
kind of think he's kind of over it and
yeah yeah maybe he's also a little over
what so there's been a there's no over
it and over
yeah yeah over it and overwhelmed right
um and so he's kind of saying I really
don't want to get involved in Capitol
Hill politics and kind of over like I'm
dealing with guys in Iraq that you know
my bama's I don't know what the guys
thinking right um so he he was
reportedly quoted as saying you and
Mitch work it out so maybe he's kind of
saying like hey guys I trust you your
adult start acting like it maybe he's
the one that's frustrated with how
ineffective Congress says well I think
he is and I think that's what they're
saying they're like he wants I think it
to me it seems like he's a professor and
he wants the government to operate the
way that it's supposed to buy the books
you know to be like Congress supposed to
work some stuff out and then get him
legislation and these things simply
don't happen which is why he has to take
the executive action that kind of stuff
um but that doesn't make him a good
politician and I think that's where his
fault has been like just believing well
Harry you got to work it out with him
cuz you guys are in Congress like
sometimes the president is supposed to
be involved mean that's what they said
Bill Clinton was a great present cuz he
was involved in all of the legislative
stuff well first I know I don't think he
ever set out to be an ideal politician I
think again that was a part of his
appeal he didn't want to fit that mold
that we've seen so many times before and
secondly I know I've seen bosses a
million times saying look I hired you
for the job how about you do it and so
you see my plate is over foot like
overflowing with things that are going
on I feel like this is an issue that
maybe if you start working on maybe I
can come around the back end and meet
you like I feel like he was just kind of
giving them the power to resolve this
issue and as far as a vacation he
doesn't strike me as a man who goes on
vacation and turns off his phone is like
her the world's gonna keep turning I'm
gonna go surfing like I don't think
that's what he does I think he's still
very in touch with his team I think he's
still very abreast of the issues and I
think he's still working even when he's
away and I feel like everything he does
is strategic yes I'm an obama fan I'm
not sure to subscribe but I'm not just
saying this because you know everything
he does is right there are things that
he could do better but I don't think
he's just like Oh check the deuces I'm
almost out I just don't think that's
where his frame of mind is well first
time I think we over it and overwhelmed
for the title for his book when he you
know when he's out like that's a great
title they do something
like really serious but over and
overwhelmed by time my time is the
president I think that's a great idea um
do you think he liked campaigning more
that's kind of so what I think about him
again I think he's a pretty decent guy
and I think he's doing the best he can
the republicans suck and get it like the
whole system's broken but he really
really liked campaigning and getting out
there with the people i don't know that
he really likes the the minutiae of it
so that's why oh how are you deal with
it like I get it like Harry that's
supposed to be your job but I think of
what another person Bill Clinton for
example I think would be in there every
day like trying to get things done again
the republicans suck i know i'm gonna be
bad it's up to no bill clinton was
incredibly likable and he was great at
relationship so I think that's not
Obama's forte he's been heavily
criticized right even amino mentioned a
centrist Democrat says my relationship
with the president is non-existent
really and I think that's a case from
many in Congress whether the Republican
or a Democrat and and sure you can argue
that this is potentially poor strategy
on his behalf but guys he got reelected
he's not trying to be reelected again he
doesn't need to be popular now and he's
had some pretty successful executive
orders also so he's kind of like oh you
guys need me for something or you don't
want to pass something i'm just gonna
sign it into law so right maybe the work
that we've done many stories on that we
could do plain or cannot throw about
that either of you think partly though
like at the end of the day the
expectations were just too high like
when you come in on hope and change like
you know to be like it's like we're six
years in now the hope and change like
doesn't seem like it really worked like
we have Obamacare we have universal
health care it's great but a lot of the
other stuff like our standing in the
world doesn't seem better it actually
seems works like was it just too much to
have a guy come in with like an idea
more than a policy you know I don't
think hope so much failed i think hope
actually worked it was like I don't we
got home I hope it's not in my notes
here okay I think I think a large part
of the country actually had hope going
in let me believe that yeah yeah the
hope work the chains okay you know I
don't think as many of the changes as
like first of all there's just too many
people that want too many different
things so everyone's not going to get
with a
one and that's me dumbing it weighed me
being bottom of the barrel here
everyone's not going to get exactly what
they want and the problem with that is
they think they should like people in
Ferguson are saying Obama come here and
take care of it what do when he lands
what do they think he's gonna do right
it just doesn't work like that and I
don't think people understand what his
presidency entails and unfortunately a
word like change is going to make people
actually think you can deliver all of
the changes they want and you catch
something you can ya bring us home no
and you mentioned that you know people
might think that a word like change
means we're gonna get changed and I
think that's actually the problem that
we had very high expectations as you
mentioned and we were incredibly naive
we thought that because we had a
Republican president before now we're
gonna have a Democratic president that
was gonna do completely the opposite you
know the other guy [ __ ] it up so badly
that this guy's gonna make it right
politicians are politicians they're
bought out there's a lot of money in
politics Democrats Republicans are more
alike than they are dissimilar and I
think that's what we need to start
focusing on not who's Republican not
who's Democrat not what campaign
marketing strategy they're using to
convince to vote for these guys in the
end there are a lot of special interest
at play here I cosine all that